let me wrap up the thousand year reign
of Christ because I don't
think I I articulated clearly enough so
I don't confuse
you there is the view that says the
thousand year reign of Christ is an
actual reign of Jesus that begins on
earth when he descends physically to the
earth now this is the view I hold to
it's called historic
premillennialism historic
premillennialism okay that's the view I
hold to where Jesus returns physically
to the Earth and he will establish his
Earthly Reign on the earth for a
thousand years now let me explain this I
need your attention because we're going
to end it with this let me explain this
this view teaches that when Jesus
returns and you got to read Revelation
20 let me give you the chapters to read
let me give you the chapters to read you
ready okay read Revelation chapter 20
please read that chap Revelation chapter
20 1 Thessalonians chapter
4: 13- 18 1 Thessalonians chapter 4 vers
13- 18
okay okay 1 Thessalonians chapter 5
verses
1-10 1 Thessalonians chapter 5 veres
1-10 write these down guys we're not
going to read them 2 Thessalonians
chapter 2 2 Thessalonians chapter 2
veres 1-2 2 Thessalon CH 2: 1-12 write
those down and then John 5:28-29
John 5:28-29 acts
2415 write these down also include
Revelation 2
26-28 Revelation 2
26-28 okay if you write those down
here's a summary of all these passages
oh and by the way 1 Corinthians 15
1 Corinthians 15 45- 58 1 Corinthians 15
45 to 58 specifically 50 to 58 write
these down 1 Corinthians 15 45- 58
specifically 50 to 58 okay now with that
said let me sum up if we take the
Thousand-Year reign of Christ as an
actual little Reign on Earth not a
symbolic Reign that began when he went
went to heaven
the Bible therefore teaches Jesus comes
down physically and he brings the
spirits of all those who have died in
Union with him then he will resurrect
their bodies reconstruct their bodies
reconstitute their bodies and unite them
with bodies now made
Immortal deathless and morally
Incorruptible morally they cannot sin
anymore they can't die anymore and he
does that only for the Believers at
first only for the Believers at first
believers who are alive on Earth pay
attention believers who are alive on
Earth we will be transformed in a
twinkling of an eye we don't die but our
bodies Our Natures are transformed by
Jesus's Almighty power where now our
bodies are made deathless and sin is
destroyed and eradicated so like the
resurrected Believers we now have bodies
that are glorious immortal deathless and
cannot sin only
us all the other unbelievers who are
alive who don't go out to make war
against Christ the armies of the
Antichrist they'll be killed they'll be
destroyed the armies pay attention the
armies will be destroyed the false
prophet right and the Beast will be
thrown into the Lake of Fire and by the
way I should have gave you this chapter
Revelation 19 read
11-21 add that as well to the equation
Revelation 19
11-21 Revelation 19
11-21 I forgot to add that anyway it
says the Beast and the false prophet
will be thrown alive into the Lake of
Fire so by the
way the first individuals thrown in the
Lake of Fire won't be Satan it will be
the Beast and the false
prophet they'll be thrown alive into the
Lake of Fire when Jesus Jesus comes down
and the armies of the beasts and the
false prophet will be killed by the
brightness of Jesus's appearance and by
the sword of his mouth and then the
birds of Heaven the F the air will Feast
on their dead bodies whether symbolic
literal it's there Revelation 19 11- 21
then Satan will be bound pay attention
Satan will be bound in the abyss not in
the Lake of Fire for a thousand years
that Thousand Years coincides with Jesus
and believers who are now made glorious
reigning on Earth over the world for a
thousand years but during that
Thousand-Year Reign they will be ruling
over those unbelievers who didn't go out
to wage war we're not part of the armies
but we're unbelievers who didn't believe
in Jesus they will remain in their
bodies of sin and death they will
continue to sin and be punished for sin
and die and they will continue to
procreate so the Bible is saying
believers who are glorified with Jesus
will rule over a world filled with
unbelievers in sinful bodies that sin
and procreate and die for a thousand
years you with me there or did I confuse
you because I got to finish it up this
fulfills revelation 22628
okay
now that means during that period
unbelievers who are not glorified
because they didn't believe will die and
be buried but they will have children
and we will reign over them for a
thousand years then after the Thousand
Years whoever am among the unbelievers
are alive will then have Satan loosed
upon them to then deceive them to
declare war against Christ and the
Saints in the holy city that's when fire
comes and consumes them all satan is
then thrown into the Lake of Fire where
the false prophet and the Beast are then
the general resurrection of everyone and
the Judgment then all unbelievers are
thrown in the Lake of Fire that's when
the earth will be changed into a new
Heaven new Earth no more sin no more
pain no more disease No More Death no
more Satan then God the father comes
down to join the son and Believers to
rule on the earth in an earth made IND
dble Immortal no more sin pain
wickedness forever and ever that's
Revelation 21 and
22 everyone with me
there you got it
now I'll do a session on this okay so
the end of Revelation is the story is
the story of God the Father coming down
to meet the son on Earth that's
Revelation 21 no take my word for it
Revelation 21:22 joining the son on
Earth where the father although he's not
a man he will appear visibly on a throne
with his son reigning on Earth with New
Jerusalem Heavenly Jerusalem coming down
over a glorified Humanity human beings
men and women made glorious
indestructible deathless morally
Incorruptible in and Earth well there be
no more sin no more evil no more
wickedness No More Death no more misery
that's Revelation 21-22 yes Tim yes this
physical Earth will be made transformed
okay now the question is because Zena
keeps asking
me why will they Reign Over unbelievers
to give
mankind a taste of what it's like to
have the perfect God man and perfect
human rulers ruling Over You No More
corrupt immoral judges politicians
lawyers corrupting justice perverting
justice oppressing the righteous and
helping the wicked to prosper because
during those thousand years unbelievers
will see what it's like when you have
the perfect God man and perfect humans
who cannot be bribed or tempted ruling
perfectly they're going to hate
it that's why Jesus is giving them a
taste you've experienced various
governments kingdoms and rules and all
have failed now experience what it's
like when the god Men shows up with a
group of glorified human beings who
cannot be tempted to corrupt Justice who
are Mo morally Incorruptible ruling over
you perfectly and passing judgment
swiftly because they can't be deceived
and misled by false witnesses to pass on
wrong verdicts
Zena you got you understand now
why you understand now why that's Jesus
is now saying
mankind you've experienced every form of
rule government corrupt politicians
corrupt judges lawyers systems that have
failed you miserably now experience what
it's like to be governed by morally
Incorruptible perfect humans and the God
man that's why they Rebel do you know
why they Rebel Sinners and sinful bodies
cannot endure such a rule because when
you have such beings Ru ruling over you
justice will be swift punishments will
be swift there will be no room for any
of the wicked to escape judgment and
they won't be able to endure it they're
going to hate it with a passion
that's why when Satan says hey here's
your chance let's get rid of the rule of
Christ and his Saints let's break free
from their shekles and rule over
ourselves that make sense
now before I end
it Revelation 22628 is a direct
quotation of Psalm 289 applied to the
Church of Jesus Christ
that they will rule over the nations
with a rod of iron and dash them like
Pottery but it's applied to Jesus and
the church ruling over the
Nations so yes it is Psalm 2 Azan Psalm
2 is directly quoted in Revelation 22628
where Jesus promises the church if they
overcome he will allow them to rule over
the nations with a rod of iron and dash
them like Pottery well that can't be
Believers ruling over believers
because a Believer will never Dash in a
Believer to death because Believers are
made Incorruptible and deathless so it
can only apply to Believers ruling over
unbelievers Revelation 2: 26-28 don't
take my word for it a direct citation of
Psalm 28-9 where Jesus extends that
promise to his church who over come they
will fulfill that promise clear or did I
put you guys to sleep
everyone got
it well it depends on what period of
church history is Ina within the first
20 years as evidenced by Christians like
papius who was a disciple of the
Apostles and the elders he believed the
Thousand Year of Christ was literal it's
when you get to the last part of the
second century start of the third
Century where people started
allegorizing the Thousand-Year Reign and
then we get to Augustine who then
impacted the Church to interpret the
Thousand Year spiritually
symbolically right everyone got it or no
did I bore you guys with this still we
got close to 400 I wanted to see 500
like earlier everyone got this or did I
confuse you
guys everyone got this all right now let
me add something I think will take place
it's not explicit but it's implied
implied
my understanding is when Jesus comes out
with Believers all those people that
took the mark of the beast they will
die not right away because again if you
read Revelation 191-211 carefully
Revelation 191-211 carefully it says
Jesus will kill the armies of the Beast
and the false prophet he's not killing
all the
nations Jesus will kill the armies of
the Beast not all unbelievers of the
Nations the armies will die but the
unbelievers of the Nations will continue
to live in their mortal sinful bodies
but those people are the ones who took
the mark of the beast meaning they are
faded for hell once they took the mark
of the beast they have now blasting the
spirit no forgiveness for them but they
will continue to have children so let's
say I'm one of those who took the mark
God forbid and I survive and I have
Jesus and I have the Believers ruling
over the Earth
so that means in California Zena and her
brother are ruling Californians and I'm
living in California and I'm living
under her Rule and her brother's rule as
they answer to Jesus who'll be ruling in
Jerusalem because Zechariah 14 which
Jesus fulfills at his second coming
he'll be ruling in Jerusalem physically
everyone else will spread all over the
Earth
okay I have
children my children are born don't take
the mark of the beast
they will have sinful bodies and they
will die too during the Thousand Year
there's a possibility for them to repent
and believe during the thousand years
because unlike me they didn't take the
mark of the beast they were born after
Jesus descends so they will have the
opportunity to live in sinful bodies
with the hope that they'll accept Christ
and not rebel against him